here we are John Waters do you think
that TV and film are responsible for
pushing the envelope when it comes to
social issues like gay marriage and now
transgender rights I don't know that the
movies today are like I don't know you
go to the movie theater now and you have
those horrible insulting pre shows where
they say if a director says action does
that mean the film starts or stops and
you have to sit there hour and be
insulted at the time the real movie and
then the trailers come on that reveal
the entire plot so you don't have to see
the movie by the time the movie comes on
you want to run out of the theater right
so I don't know if they have that power
anymore I dread
I think TV does more than like I think
unfortunately it does the independent
world I know is over you know I think
it's easier to get your what you're
trying to your product on TV and more
people see it and you make more money
certainly than it is to have a little
independent film even though I still do
go to movies and we and we have a lot
more diversity now right with the awards
Oscars is supposed to be a lot more
diverse that weren't the most averse
that we've ever seen in a while and so
there's been some great movies and
hidden figures fences gosh I can't even
think of olive oil the GCL Isabel -
Barry no I did not know that but but any
some of that just liberal feeling guilty
from last year and going I actually wish
it we got a vote of the black people
this but know these movies are actually
good though oh yeah they're the right
movie whatever they are but award shows
are never about justice
no no hey we've seen those out here can
you imagine what they're gonna be like
of the oscars like they're gonna be so
many speeches already to 1 a.m. we
actually go right I couldn't agree more
and also like la-la-land really sorry I
didn't know I did not watch it I feel
terrible I use almost all online i BN
terrible images so lemon they were
flying through the air I was out of
there oh thanks but it's sort of no
sense of magic is so narcissistic you
know another movie there about movies
about us you know it was Hollywood with
making love right itself well right what
is it
it was come on yeah but what didn't
Birdman win
couple years yeah like that you know a
Mossad leader and Italy you could not in
like them is it sounds right there oh I
like Birdman but I'm in a minion to
stand more diversity more yeah that's
like why we get the same thing okay
Twitter announced new guidelines this
week to combat bullying on their site is
there any way they might have to censor
the president well isn't isn't that his
right some some time but it is at his
wife's pet project right now bullying
cyberbullying young not even living
there can you imagine if Michelle Obama
didn't live in the White House how
batshit they would have went I got the
very very funny [ __ ] I thought the same
thing I always thought like I've been
thinking if President Obama said it's
like just 1/10 of what double jobs are
saying the Republicans would be
apoplectic they would be screaming from
the mountain for Fiat joke on with three
different why exactly or pushing
Michelle Obama's you know clothing
lemonade we're reading Toria black Garda
Station grab grab you by the [ __ ] yeah
why on earth the first lady's you
imagine if Jackie had a sunglass line or
lighting board had beer beer I mean that
was another gross story
I know you can't talk about is your pay
for the deli my own but Milani is suing
because the Daily Mail I didn't even
call her this they were just quoting
somebody else and I think they said it
wasn't true saying somebody says I think
the one guy did say it was try to blame
her for suing for that in the work okay
but not well I mean the bloggers who for
what that have said was that it's it's
it's causing me a great opportunity I
know I know basically that break it in
yeah I mean the Trump family is just so
naked about we're using this to make
money yeah they're very hot for the
presidency yeah apparently okay will
statements from athletes like Steph
Curry who this week took issue with the
CEO of Under Armour's support for Trump
effect how the sporting world engages
with politics I don't know this story it
Baltimore
what are they just playful and why don't
the actors just at a why don't they all
just keep out of follow okay be there
exactly silly argument now they all
right no because because why don't you
just do things with a newspaper and
don't talk about politics why sure you
want a newspaper but I'm talking about
but why should anyone why should a
plumber not be able to talk about
politics no they should all be other
talking to who will be saying that one
wasn't about doctors and what's a
procession of lovie actors wandering up
I'm ranting about Donald Trump but you
know how I thank you mom and dad
faint your agent say you love the movie
defense it's a pop down yeah am i wrong
foot now no I don't think you're wrong
about that I don't I don't think it
helps either I think it makes Trump
voters hate well babe I think any Trump
voters are Meryl Streep movie no ever
99th one I think they saw the river wild
release for Kevin Bacon being so uptight
about shopping at Nordstrom you know
it's not like a lot of trumps supporters
shop there it's like them worrying if I
go to JP Lube it doesn't happen a lot
John you got a jiffy lubes yeah I don't
I don't even know how to pull in
yep
and you're one of the few guys that
doesn't have to pull out either find it
hours covered yes John my faith Lee
pullin does it be look mrs. Robinson
this is good John do you think Americans
are less easily shocked by crude movies
and television and they used to be I
think now Hollywood makes hundred
million dollar gross out movies that
aren't funny I think now it's over you
know if you're trying too hard it
doesn't work man they do right they do
and too much you know that's why I went
reverse ivory shot pink flamingos for
children for an art show I did call
Kitty flamingos and I took all the dirty
parts out so the parents Watson thinks
who know that kids like Oh talk about
[ __ ] a chicken or they and then but
they don't they don't so the kids are
innocent but the parents are more
perverse watching it so it worked
actually in Reverse it's better to learn
about it in gentleman up the schoolyard
really yeah I don't mind [ __ ] a
chicken but well decorated later so it
was some accurate correct
it wasn't a snuff movie that's not
talking about his new show yeah
Kareem oh do you think that grassroots
anti-trump movements are unified enough
to defeat him yes I think that to this
week or the last couple of weeks we saw
we've seen some great games we won the
court the court ruling yesterday let's
not forget very early on very early on
before even Trump got into the
administration there was the ethics
office that the Republicans are trying
to gut and what did what happened people
started calling their congressional
members and it stopped so I think there
are a list of things that you see by
vice president pence voting for the
first time to actually break a tie to
get the education secretary in unheard
of and I think there are things that are
happening that are faster than having to
break the table having to break the tide
right there are things there happening
and faster paced and even the Tea Party
and also
that to me the most encouraging thing is
Republicans the judge who made the
struck down the Muslim ban has a Bush
appointee yes and the judge three
nothing on the appellate courts that's
right even the Republican leave another
Publix is a toxic insanity of origin
tree across the country it's been
butchered and and also democratic thank
you very much everybody
[Applause]